thank you
I declare the 11th emergency special
session of the general assembly resumed
before proceeding further I would like
to remind members that all meeting
participants are encouraged to consider
wearing a mask while indoors
including in the General Assembly Hall
and in in conference conference rooms
members will recall that in paragraph
three of its resolution es11-3
of 7th of April 2022 the assembly
decided I quote to adjourn the 11th
emergency special session of the general
assembly temporarily
and to authorize the president of the
general assembly to resume its upon
request from member states end of quote
in this regard
I should like to draw the attention of
the delegations to document a slash es
11 8.
which contains a letter dated third of
October
2022 from the permanent representatives
of Albania and Ukraine to the United
Nations
requesting the resumption of the 11th
emergency special session of the general
assembly
I intend to conduct the proceedings of
this meeting in accordance with the
rules of procedure of the general
assembly
past practices of its emergency special
sessions
in accordance with rule 63
of the rules of procedure of the general
assembly
the president and vice presidents of the
77th session Shall Serve in the same
capacity at the resumed 11th emergency
special session
may I take it that it is the wish of the
Jannah assembly to decide that the
credentials Committee of the 77th
session
should serve for the resumed 11
emergency special session
so decided
in keeping with established practice
I should now like to invite the
attention of the agenda assembly to
document a slash ES 11-9
concerning member states that are in
areas in the payment of their financial
contributions to the United Nations
within the terms of Article 19 of the
charter
may I take it that the assembly Julie
takes note of the information contained
in this document
it is so decided
and this connection may I further take
it that it is the wish of the general
assembly to follow the provisions of the
resolution
77-2 of 7th of October 2022
by which the cameras
principle and Somalia are permitted to
vote in the general assembly until the
end of the of its 77th session
and to also allow these member states to
vote at the 11th emergency special
session
the general assembly
will now resume its consideration of
agent item five
entitled letter quote letter dated very
2014
from the permanent representative of
Ukraine to the United Nations
addressed to the president of the
security Council
2014 slash
136 end of quote
in this connection the assembly has
before before it a draft resolution
contained in document a slash es 11
L5
I give the floor to the representative
Albania on point of order
thank you president I have a point of
order to raise before we proceed with
agenda item 5 of the 11th emergency
special session
would like to propose that the General
Assembly adopts a decision confirming
that the general assembly will apply
rule
87b of the rules of procedure to take
recorded vote by electronic means when
action is taken on the resolution L5
and that action will not be taken by a
secret ballot
the reason for this proposed decision is
that Russia has circulated a proposal to
all member states
formally requesting detection on the
resolution via through a secret ballot
in the interest of avoiding confusion
the ga should clarify this issue now
Russia's proposal is an attempt to
threaten transparency in the ga
wouldn't we all want transparency from
the International Community
if a neighboring country invaded and
attempted to Annex a portion of our
territory
would any member state of the ga support
a secret ballot if it was their own
territory that someone was trying to
Annex
the Russian Federation is citing as
president of
1977 decision to hold the secret ballot
in the unga
that decision only applies to the narrow
choice of the venue for a un session
in fact the rest of the resolution was
not decided by secret ballot
indeed it was adopted by consensus
the decision that Russian Federation
cites is not applicable as president
a decision on a venue is similar to a
decision to elect member states or
individuals to U.N bodies
which are held by secret ballot
there is no precedent for the ga to hold
the secret ballot on a non-venue issue
let alone on an important question of
International Peace and security
for the entire history of the UN
substantive resolutions such as the one
we have before us today have been held
by a recorded vote as provided in the
rules of procedure
therefore there is no basis for
suspending the rules of procedure on
voting
we should not play with words and we
should not establish dangerous
precedence
even if it is legally possible to
suspend the rules of procedure it is
entirely unjustified for this resolution
to conduct a secret ballot on a ga
decision would go against Decades of
President and undermine the practices of
the world's most representative
deliberative body
in this case we require request all
member states to vote in favor of our
proposed decision to confirm that rule
87b will apply when action is taken on
the draft resolution L5 and that action
will not be taken by secret ballot I
thank you
I thank the representative Albania
the representative of Albania has moved
that decision on draft resolution a
slash es 11 slash L5
be made by a recorded vote pursuant to
rule 87
of the Rosa procedure which provides
that I quote any representative May
request a recorded vote
and of course
and do not buy secret ballot
now I give the floor to the
representative of the Russian Federation
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we will introduce such a proposal I
think
foreign
the representative of the Russian
Federation has made an objection to the
motion
pursuant to rule 71 of the rules of
procedure the point of order shall be
immediately decided
I shall now put to the recorded vote the
motion by the representative of Albania
that decision on draft resolution a
slash
es11 L5
be made by a recorded vote and not by
secret ballot
the recorded vote on this motion will be
decided by a simple majority of members
present and voting
we shall now begin the voting process
those in favor of the motion by the
representative of Albania
that decision on draft resolution a
slash es 11 slash L5
be taken by a recorded vote and not to
buy secret ballot
the
delegation of the Syrian Arab Republic
is asking for the floor I'll give the
floor if it is only on the conduct of
the vote
shukran
thank you Mr President
what I understood
the suspension of an article and not um
to continue and proceed with albanians
are here proposal was reaction if my
understanding was correct the Russian
Federation requested something different
I did not propose the issue of a secret
ballot I hope to clarify this situation
so let me continue
thank you much for the intervention let
me continue the recorded vote on this
motion will be decided by a simple
majority of member states present and
voting
we shall now begin the voting process
those in favor of the motion by the
representative of Albania
that decision on draft resolution a
slash es 11 L5
be taken by a recorded vote and not to
buy secret ballot please signify
those against
extensions
members are reminded that at this stage
the general assembly is voting on the
motion of the representative of Albania
and not on the draft resolution itself
the general assembly is now voting on
the motion by the representative of
Albania the decision on draft resolution
a stroke EST 11
L5 be taken by recorded Ford and not by
secret ballot those who vote Yes will be
voting in favor of the use of a recorded
vote as proposed by Albania
those who vote no will be voting against
the motion proposed by Albania and a
favorite and in favor of a secret ballot
will all delegations confirm that their
votes are accurately reflected on the
screen
the voting has completed
please lock the machine
the result of the vote is as follows in
favor 107.
against 13
abstention 39.
the motion by the representative of
Albania is adopted
the Jannah assembly therefore will take
decision on draft resolution a slash es
11
L5 by a recorded vote after the debate
on the item
we shall now continue with a debate on
agent item 5.
foreign
excellencies
the war in Ukraine
should have been never started
but it will end one day
guns will be silent
but when
at what cost
how many people will have died
how many families separated
how much more suffering endured
what will Ukraine look like when peace
returns
and what will the world look like
so much has been destroyed
there will be no vectors
everyone will lose
is threatening communities throughout
the world
I thank the Secretary General for
leading on the Black Sea Green
initiative
by the United Nations
yes have a quarter of which is
delivered directly to
low-income countries
we shall act together
to achieve the full implementation of
this initiative
imperative
that we secure its removal renewal
Beyond mid-november
excellencies
as the horrors in Ukraine were not
enough
we are forced to live with a constant
fear of nuclear disaster I commend the
work of the iaea
to ensure the safety of nuclear plants
in the war zone
the iaea has warned there is I quote
playing with fire
end of quote
when it comes to nuclear issues
any irresponsible action or statement is
unacceptable
and any threat of using nuclear weapons
should be universally condemned
the U.N Charter is clear
the general assembly has been clear
the Secretary General has been clear
aggression is illegal
the GE resolution of 14th of December
1974.
defines aggression as the use of Armed
Force by a State against the sovereignty
territorial Integrity or political
independence of another state
this act
is called as inconsistent with the
charter
invading a neighbor
is illegal
Article 4 of the U.N Charter states that
I quote
all members shall refrain in their
international relations from the threat
or use of force against the territorial
Integrity or political independence of
any state
end of quote
annexing territories of other countries
by force
is illegal
the G resolution of 24th of October
1970.
the Declaration on principles of
international law
concerning friendly relations and
cooperation among states
has reinforced that the territory of a
state shall not be object of acquisition
by another state using from resulting
from a threat or use of forth
it is incompatible
with the purposes and principles of the
charter
and as the Secretary General pointed out
the referenda in the occupied regions I
quote
cannot be called a genuine expression of
the popular will
end of course
when it comes a daily routine to watch
images of destroyed cities and Scattered
bodies
we lose our Humanity
we must find a political solution
based on the U.N Charter and the
international law
we need to keep the door open for
diplomacy
the fighting between Russia and Ukraine
must stop
as the general assembly has decided in
its resolution adopted on March the
second
2022 I quote
troops of the Russian Federation must be
withdrawn from the territory of Ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders end of quote without shared
rules
a world
without peace
a world
without future
we must recommit to the values
principles and purposes of the charter
if you want to move forward as a global
community
we must provide answers
the world is looking to us
thank you
now I give the door to the distinguished
representative of Ukraine to introduce
draft resolution a slash es 11 L5
[Music]
foreign
good afternoon
is going to be a very difficult task for
me today
for many reasons
is barely 4 P.M in New York
but my day has started almost 14 hours
to go
it started 14 hours ago because my
country
was under attack
my immediate family was in a residential
building
under attack
unable to go to a bomb shelter because
there was no electricity
because Russia has already killed some
of my family members
and we see no end to that cruelty
but let me start
with a quote from a very respected
gentleman in his country
from the president who was the first
president ever directly elected in his
country in a democratic way
and that is Jose cerrato
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Uruguay
at the six plenary meeting of the U.N
conference
on International Organization
in San Francisco on May the 1st 1945 and
I quote
a stable insane piece cannot be attained
if nothing is done
for the democratization of the world
and the rule of freedom
peace and democracy
constitute complementary objectives
Each of which is a guarantee and a
motive for the either
in this Regard in the proposed
International Organization
that should not be admitted Nations
professing doctrines of aggression and
War
which are inclined to undermine or
destroy the order of juridical Peace in
the world
however in order to be a member of
international Society
it is not enough to present the titles
of peace loving Nations
but it is also necessary to be a freedom
loving Nation end of quote Jose Serrato
of Uruguay
this is how our predecessor predecessors
so the way to save succeeding
Generations from this courage of War at
the dawn of our organization 77 years
ago
unfortunately
you can hardly hope for a stable and
sane peace as long
as an unstable and insane dictatorship
exists in your vicinity
a dictatorship that actively uses
missile Terror against the civilian
population and infrastructure
today terrorist Russia sell the capital
city of Kiev and many other Ukrainian
cities throughout the country with at
least 84 missiles and two dozen uavs
energy facilities
residential buildings
schools and universities
museums and Crossroads in the city
centers were among the targets that the
Russian defense Ministry later declared
legitimate
the entire world has once again seen the
true face of the terrorist state that
kills our people
suffering defeats on the battlefield
Russia takes it out on the peaceful
residence of Ukrainian cities
today's strike killed at least 14
civilians and 97th were wounded
deliberate targeting of civilians is a
war crime
by launching missile attacks on
civilians
sleeping in their homes or rushing to
work children going to schools Russia
has proven once again that it is a
terrorist state that must be deterred in
the strongest possible ways
we need this to prevent further heinous
atrocities and to secure our
achievements within this organization
the UN has survived many challenges
including block confrontation and Soviet
threats
In This Very whole
address to the world
threats addressed to the U.N
in each Secretary General
as king Hussein of Jordan
said in 1960
standing exactly where yet almost from
the birth Soviet Union has sought to
destroy the United Nations
to its deliberations
to block its decisions
to demean the reputation of the security
Council and the secretary and the
general assembly
end of cooked
I sign under each of these wars in 2022
standing exactly where the leader of
Jordan was 62 years ago
what we are witnessing now is an attempt
by Russia to revive the so-called
Brezhnev Doctrine envisaging that the
Soviet Union could limit the principle
of prohibition of the use of force if it
is if its interest in other states
within so-called Zone influence of
influence were challenged
incompatibility of this Doctrine with
the UN Charter was clear even for the
Soviet Union
and at the end of the day the USSR had
to officially give it up let me quote
president gorbachov
it is evident for example that force and
the threat of force can no longer be and
should not be instruments of foreign
policy
set the the then Soviet president in
this very whole in December 1988
these walls however mean nothing for
modern Russia
who is occupying the USSR permanent seat
at the security Council and thus is
allowed to block any action by the
council to restore International Peace
and security
Mr President Russia now tries its best
to bring us back to the 1930s
not even 1940s
when Hitler destroys Sovereign Nations
by invasion
fake referendums and Angelus
and we are now at a Tipping Point where
the United Nations will either restore
its credibility or it will ultimately
fall in failure
and if if the latter happens we should
blame nobody but ourselves
because it is our responsibility to
defend the principles of the UN Charter
a trail of blood
is Left Behind the Russian delegation
when it enters the general assembly
and the hole is filled up with the smell
of smoldering human flesh
that's what we have tolerated too long
in Syria
that's what is happening today in
Ukraine
same dictator in the Kremlin
same Russian generals well known for
scorched Earth tactics
in Wars LED in Syria and in chechnya and
today in Ukraine
since 23rd September Russia has been
committing another crime against
international law and its principles
committing it in an actual integrity and
the inviability of borders where a
privilege with limited access not the
right of every nation
the Sham referendums in four Ukrainian
regions followed by unlawful Decisions
by the Russian president and and
Parliament served this very purpose and
thus pose an existential threat to the
United Nations and its Charter
ukrainians can tell you what our world
will look like if this erosion of The
un's credibility is not stopped
if complete disregard for the U.N
Charter by a country occupying a
permanent seat in the security Council
meets any response but zero tolerance
death
human suffering and destruction are
immediate outcomes
as it was in the city of zaparita on the
night of the 9th of October when Russia
fired over 20 missiles on residential
areas which killed at least 13 and
injured 60 civilians including six
children
and let me remind you that zapparesia is
the main city of one of the four regions
that Russia has claimed following the
Sham referendums
Moscow has even included the reference
to zaparita in his Constitution
please forgive me use of the term
constitution in relation to that
voiceless piece of paper
it is indeed hard if not impossible for
a normal human being to comprehend the
logic of Putin and his cronies
first
you claim the seizure of an area of a
neighboring sovereign state under the
pretext of protection of local
population
and then
you kill this population with dozens of
missiles
it is clear however that the so-called
sham referendum served as an element of
the Russian aggression against Ukraine
an element that was hostily prepared and
implemented in response to the
successful process of liberation of the
occupied territories by the army of
Ukraine
the so-called referendums bore no
relation
at all with what we are used to calling
expression of the popular will
neither from the illegal nor from the
technical modalities
we are grateful to the Secretary General
Antonio buterish
who was very clear and explicit
in his condemnation of the Russian
actions
and as he said a quote
any decision to proceed with the
annexation would have no legal value and
deserves to be condemned
it cannot be reconciled with the
international legal framework
stands against everything the
International Community is meant to
stand for
it flaws the purposes and principles of
the United Nations it must not be
accepted and of quote said the Secretary
General
distinguished colleagues Ukraine is the
in indeed is the immediate Target of the
Russian attacks on the ground but it is
not Ukraine that Russia ultimately aims
at
let me reiterate it again it is our
future that is now at stake
the future that cannot be secured by
separate countries or Regional
Arrangements if the United Nations is
relegated to the backstage of global
processes
let me recall that
the very first purpose of this
organization which is enshrined in
article 1.
of each other is to maintain
International Peace and security and to
do that and to that end to take
effective Collective measures for the
prevention and removal of threats to the
peace and for the suppression of Acts of
aggression
paragraph four of Article 2 of the
charter constitutes the most important
principle with regards to the above
mentioned purpose
in particular we are speaking about the
threat and use of force against the
territorial integrity and political
independence of Ukraine
violation of paragraph 4 of Article 2 of
the charter is a violation of the
Cornerstone of the peace in the Chatham
the heart of the charter and even basic
rule of contemporary international law
as it has been labeled in legal writings
dear colleagues the only thing that
Russia is afraid of is our strong Unity
of purpose in defense of the U.N Charter
in defense of the right of every country
to benefit from respect for its
sovereignty and territorial integrity
we have to save the United Nations
not for the sake of this whole
high level weeks or other procedural and
protocol issues that have been our
routine since 1945.
we need to do it for the sake of
ourselves as most of us will find
ourselves extremely vulnerable and
unprotected if the Russian vision of the
future prevails
a future where only nuclear power
size of the Armed Forces and number of
Warships in aircraft matter
how many of you would feel safe and
secure in such a world
how many of you
would deprive your children of the right
to to freely decide their own future
the answer seems obvious and we have to
Rally around the U.N Charter and to
reconfirm that its principles remain a
strong shield to protect All Nations
large or small
members of alliances
or neutral ones
on all continents
that was the spirit of our common
commitment to save succeed spirit that
guided our predecessors in San Francisco
77 years ago
The Same Spirit should guide us now in
particular during the vote on the draft
resolution
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
defending the principles of the UN
Charter
and to illustrate
what unites us all
even if countries are 10 000 kilometers
apart
let me finish with a quote from the
French foreign minister
Josh bidov
at the conference in San Francisco in
1945
and I quote
Justice
is another word we must reinstate in all
its loftiness
Justice in keeping with International
democracy
Justice which gave us gives full
recognition to the rights of all
countries
including those which do not come under
the generally recognized term of great
powers
a point
I would particularly stress that the
French foreign minister in San Francisco
U.N Charter
for each country
for each of our citizens for your
families for your children
a vote for justice
and they urge you to support
the draft I thank you very much
[Applause]
I thank the distinguished representative
of Ukraine
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
Russian Federation
colleagues
with procedural issues we you just you
see us
and outrageous
fraudible Brett um the president of the
general assembly played a keywords
deprived the members of the United
States
of course under these conditions we did
not vote
in the strongest possible words
and what we
instead of that
um our opponents talk about is this fair
play
equal dialogue of sovereign
specifically to push forward a narrative
against one state the Russians
Foundations
at least
long before then are being left outside
[Music]
many years foreign
[Music]
and foreign
the
[Music]
[Music]
through a very clear legal status of
those regions and exceptions
were threatened with eucharanization
executed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but also to the responsible steps made
by the key of regime these steps
in order to act again
countries of nature
to deliver a preventive nucleus
happens
these appeals are threatening all of us
the evidence
warned that this will not be conducted
when you do these acts of sabotages
regime is on the same level with the
most applications
of this religion
that they speak foreign
I thank the distinguished representative
of the Russian Federation
generation to clarify exactly what
Russia would like to put in motion
pretty strong
response
I'll propose yes but
studies
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
ladies and gentlemen the distinguished
representative of the Russian Federation
has moved that rule 87 be suspended
in order to take a decision on draft
resolution a slash es 11 L5 by secret
ballot
this would constitute the
reconsideration of the decision taken by
the general assembly
to adopt the motion submitted by Albania
I wish to recall rule 81 of the rules of
procedure
rule 81 provides as follows
when a proposal has been adopted to
reject or rejected
it may not be reconsidered at the same
session unless
the general assembly by two-thirds
majority of the members present and
voting so decides
permission to speak on emotion
to reconsider shall be accorded only to
two speakers opposing the motion
after which it shall be immediately put
to vote
first you want to rule 81 of the Russo
procedure
up to two speakers opposing the motion
by the Russian Federation
for reconsideration
may may make statements
does any delegation opposing the motion
by the Russian Federation wish to take
the floor
and Ukraine
I recognize the delegation of Albania
thank you thank you Mr President I'm
taking the floor to object to the
request from the Russian Federation
to hold the motion on this issue as you
already as we already said we we made
the the decision it's already made and
we don't see any reason to revisit this
uh decision the motion was approved with
107 votes and the clearly applicable
rules of procedure on voting
thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
you all being here now I recognize the
distinguished representative of Ukraine
well thank you very much Mr President I
believe it is a clear case of abuse by
one delegation
of the general assembly manipulation
with the rules of procedure I think that
the wish of the general assembly was
overwhelming
so we
call on the Russian delegation to stop
putting hurdles on the way of the
general assembly to carry on the
decision of the very important debate
that we will have that we have in front
of us thank you very much
I thank the distinguished representative
of Ukraine and before going to vote I
recognize that the distinguished
representative of Russian Federation
wants to speak on the point of order
um
[Music]
and the article 1771 of the rules of
procedure is the one that applies to our
proposal thank you
I think the distinguished represent the
representative of the Russian Federation
thank you
thank you
ladies and gentlemen
the distinguished representative of the
Russian Federation has challenged the
president's ruling
that this is a reconsideration of the
decision just taken
rule 71 is applicable in this case
and the relevant parts of this rule
states as follows
I quote a representative May appeal
against the ruling of the president
the appeal shall be immediately put to
the vote and the president's ruling
shall stand unless overruled by the by
majority of the members present and
voting
thus I shall now put to a recorded vote
the appeal that is a challenge against
the president's ruling
may I point out that those who vote Yes
will be voting in favor of the challenge
submitted by the distinguished
representative of the Russian Federation
we shall now begin the voting process
those in favor of the challenge
by the distinguished representative of
the Russian Federation against the
president's ruling
that this is a reconsideration of the
decision just taken please signify
those against and upside abstention the
general assembly is now voting on The
Challenge made by the representative of
the Russian Federation
those agreeing with the challenge made
by the Russian Federation should press
yes
those disagreeing with a challenge by
the Russian Federation should vote no
will all delegations confirm that their
votes are accurately reflected on the
screen
the voting has been completed please
lock the machine
the result of the vote is as follows in
favor of the appeal
14. against
100
abstention 38
the ruling of the president is upheld
thank you
ladies and gentlemen since the
president's ruling is upheld
the general assembly will now vote on
the motion to reconsider the decision
adopted by the Gen assembly
those in favor of reconsidering the
decision should vote Yes
those that are not in favor of
reconsidering the motion should vote no
the general assembly is now voting on
the motion to reconsider that decision
adopted earlier by the general assembly
those in favor of the reconsideration of
the decision already taken taken earlier
by the assembly should vote Yes
and those against such reconsideration
should vote no
will all delegations confirm that their
votes are accurately reflected on the
screen
the voting has been completed please
lock the machine
the result of the Voting is as follows
in favor 16
against 104
abstention
34.
the Gen assembly has thus decided not to
reconsider the motion
and now I give the floor
I recognize the Russian Federation
willing to take the floor on point of
order
correct Mr President the
um
addresses partially but I wanted to say
something else and it is this
to move on to making a decision on the
[Music]
um
extending this over several days and we
have a very long list of speakers
the resolution is a highly illogical
step says such an approach give
additional opportunity
pressure on those countries who had
supported this
against uh
those who should be twisting people's
arms they are four we um propose uh um
and this is an official motion that we
vote on the draft resolution now and not
after we listen to all the speakers
thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of the Russian Federation
back
may I ask the distinguished
representative of the Russian Federation
to clarify
whether it has requested
to close the debate under rule 75
in order to proceed immediately to
action on the draft resolution
now we will vote on that and then we'll
continue with the debate on the on the
issue thank you
and and
I think I understood the
point of the distinguished
representative of the of the Russian
Federation
and I intend to conduct the proceeding
of this meeting in accordance with the
Russo procedure of the general assembly
and the past practices of its emergency
emergency special sessions
and the practice of gem assembly
including the emergency special session
and to proceed with the debate and then
come to the action on the draft
resolution
I recognize the distinguished
representative of the Russian Federation
willing to take the floor on point of
order
when
he was from similar machines but we are
in admiration courageous decisions
have there been instances where the
decisions
the uh voting took place at the end of
the debate according to what you just
said we cannot agree with the approach
that you just put forward
means that the assembly moves over to
the consideration of the draft
resolution instead of doing that we're
gonna have to wait possibly several days
possibly until Thursday and it's only
then that we will be able to put on the
resolution and we do know who benefits
from such a scenario Mr President it's
unfortunate that you're playing into
this unfortunately
stage is to express our regret at the
decisions that you made
um
[Music]
all of the ways of conducting the
proceedings we regret them all of the
ways of conducting the procedures that
you have demonstrated today
I hear the opinion of the distinguished
representative of the Russian Federation
and his opinion will be duly reflected
in the records of the meeting
now we we proceed with it
Mr President honorable colleagues I have
the honor to speak on behalf of eight
Nordic Baltic countries Estonia Denmark
Finland Iceland Lithuania Norway Sweden
and my own country Latvia
Mr President February 24th this year
Russia launched its brutal full-scale
invasion of Ukraine in the blatant
violation of international law and the
U.N Charter
by this war of aggression aided by
Belarus
Russia has deliberately violated the
fundamental rights of all states to
Independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity
Russia's military aggression and
systematic violations of international
humanitarian law and human rights and
atrocities committed against the people
of Ukraine constitute to cause grave
human rights suffering in Ukraine as
well as globally
moreover Russia has chosen further
escalation
we resolutely missile attacks on
residential areas power stations
Railways Trade Centers and bridges in
Kiev the parisia levith nipro and other
Ukrainian cities launched by Russia
there is no military purpose there the
only goal of precious deliberate attacks
is to cause death and destruction to
civilian people
with its military force Russia has
organized chambray Veranda as a pretext
for a subsequent illegal attempt to
annexed four Ukrainian regions lugansk
Donetsk Harrison and the parisia
following the pattern of the attempted
illegal annexation of Crimea Ukraine in
2014.
we reiterate our unwavering support to
Ukraine's Independence sovereignty and
territorial Integrity within its
International recognized borders
landlord for Russian attempts to change
the status of the temporary occupied
Ukrainian regions have no legal validity
we will never recognize the so-called
results and claimed consequences of
these sham referenda
Russia's faulted attempts to validate
voting at gunpoint goes against the core
principles of international law has also
reiterated by the Secretary General on
September 29 2022
they are now and void and cannot produce
any legal effect whatsoever
Mr President there is no such thing as
legitimate referendum amidst brutal
Warfare and widespread and systematic
violations of international humanitarian
law human rights violations and abuses
there is no such thing as a valid
annexation of the state's territory by
another state as a result of threats and
direct use of force
in this respect we recall that on the
international law all states are obliged
not to recognize Russia's attempted
illegal annexation of Ukrainian
territory
colleagues Russians and law football in
Ukraine constitutes a direct attack on
the rules-based International System and
a threat to International Peace and
security
we will not accept this blatant
violation of the core principles of the
U.N Charter and the suffering of
millions in its wake
we will not accept Russia's unlawful
behavior that jeopardizes International
Peace and security
we reject Russia's brutality in the
strongest possible terms and the
International Community will hold Russia
uncountable for its actions
there shall be no impunity
on Friday September 30th the security
Council draft resolution on the Hashem
referenda failed to be adopted due to a
single member Russia's casting its veto
we deeply regret this
we do however acknowledge the special
report of the security Council on the
use of the veto which informs us on
discussions today
Mr President our stance is clear a world
without respect for sovereignty
territorial integrity and the
rules-based international order cannot
stand
therefore we firmly we must firmly and
collectively reject Russia's claim
Hashem referenda and illegal attempt to
Annex any part of Ukrainian territory
we must collectively continue to insist
that Russia completely and unilaterally
withdraw its troops from the territory
of Ukraine within its International
recognized borders Russia must comply
comply with the 16th of March order of
the icj which is binding on the parties
and stop its aggression against Ukraine
we must have called The Core principles
of international law in the U.N Charter
and we must underline that Russia's
unacceptable threats on the use of
nuclear weapons is include threatens
International Peace and security
colleagues we will continue to firmly
stand with Ukraine and we will continue
to provide support to Ukraine for as
long as it takes in line with the U.N
Charter and international law Ukraine
has the inherent right to defend it
itself against Russia's aggression and
to restore its sovereignty within
International recognized borders
we know what the annexation and
occupation are
we have experienced it during and after
the second World War therefore we must
do everything possible to defend the U.N
Charter
the Nordic and Baltic countries will
therefore vote in favor of this
resolution and we call on all member
states to do the same I thank you Mr
President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Latvia and now I give the flow to
this the distinction representative of
Fiji speaking on behalf of the Pacific
island forum
Mr Mr President excellencies
I have the honor to deliver this
statement on behalf of member states of
the Pacific island Forum with presence
here at the United Nations
this is the third time our Forum members
have addressed an emergency special
session of this distinguished assembly
regarding the ongoing illegal invasion
of Ukraine by the Russian Federation we
spoke out to condemn The Invasion we
spoke humanitarian access
today we are here again
speak in defense of Ukraine's
territorial sovereignty and integrity in
light of Russian federation's attempt to
illegally Annex four regions of eastern
Ukraine namely donate luhans Kirsten and
zaparita
the president many islands and countries
of our Blue Pacific continent are
diverse with their own unique histories
however there is much which unites us
including values of Justice fairness and
shared Prosperity underpinning this
Unity is a shared belief in the value of
the multilateral system and Shrine in
the U.N Charter and its principles
the Russian federations attempted
illegal annexation of parts of Ukrainian
territory is a clear violation of the
principles of the U.N Charter and of
international law
the charter cannot simply be worn like a
prestigious cloak only to be discarded
when perceived geopolitical interests
are at stake every instance of such
Behavior risks wearing a thin dirtying
it and potentially even destroying it
like our very air water and land the
charter must be treasured if it is
if it is to in turn provide sustenance
to our Global family the many states of
the Blue Pacific continent understand
this intimately we also understand the
terrible human and environmental cost of
nuclear weapons in light of our regions
history regarding nuclear testing it is
unacceptable that the use of nuclear
weapons is openly threatened by a
nuclear weapon state
we therefore strongly condemn Russia's
latest threats to use nuclear weapons
against Ukraine we also strongly support
International efforts to safeguard
Ukrainian nuclear facilities against
damage intentional or otherwise Mr
President is a member of the security
Council the Russian Federation is an
even greater responsibility to uphold
the charter the principles of
sovereignty dignity and peaceful
resolutions of all disputes our Pacific
island Forum Family the schools for the
Russian Federation to seize its
attempted illegal annexation of
Ukrainian territory to de-escalate the
current situation and to withdraw behind
its internationally recognized borders
in order for a peaceful resolution to
the conflict to be achieved such a
resolution will not be found through
coercion violence torture bullets and
bombs it will come through diplomacy
Justice and respect for the values rules
in Norms which sustain our Global
community and which animate these
hollowed pools from climate change to
covet recovery hunger and irredractable
conflicts there's simply too much at
stake for this needless illegal War to
continue to undermine our shared work
you have the full statement Mr President
I thank you very much
I thank the distinguished representative
of Fiji and now I give the flower to the
distinguished representative of the
European Union speaking on behalf of its
member states
foreign
thank you president before delivering
this statement allow me to say how
uphold we are
but the attacks carried out today by
Russia against Kiev and other cities
across Ukraine
such indiscriminate attacks on civilians
or war crimes and we are committed to
holding the perpetrators to account
president I have the honor to speak on
behalf of the EU and its member states
the Canada countries North Macedonia
Montenegro Albania Ukraine and the
Republic of Moldova the country of the
stabilization Association process and
potential candidate bosniazzegovina as
well as Georgia Andorra Monaco and San
Marino align themselves with this
statement
we welcome the decision to reconvene
this emergency special session
past week European Union has facilitated
a resolution to condemn Russia's
organization of the illegal so-called
referenda in regions within's Ukraine's
internationally recognized borders
as well as its subsequent attempted a
legal illegal annexation of Ukraine's
regions of donets luhans Kirsten and
zaporizia
we want to sincerely thank all the
delegations that engaged with us on this
text
during the transparent and inclusive
process we have made every effort to
include the proposals we have received
from other delegations
we believe the result is a concise and
focused text that all of us should be
able to support
we therefore strongly encourage all UN
member states to co-sponsor and vote in
favor of the resolution
and in this respect let me say that we
are very grateful the disassembly has
decided to follow its long-established
tradition of voting in a transparent
manner
president dear colleagues
debate concerns every single one of us
today's discussion is about upholding
the charter of the United Nations and
core principles of our organization
it is about respecting the most basic
principles of international law
by willfully undermining the rules-based
international order and blatantly and
repeatedly violating Ukraine's
Independence sovereignty and territorial
Integrity Russia is putting Global Peace
and security at risk
if we do not condemn the actions of the
Russian Federation in Ukraine today
we will end up condoning similar blatant
attacks on any and all of our countries
tomorrow
we therefore firmly reject an
inequivocally condemned the attempted
illegal annexation by Russia of
Ukraine's donets luhans zaporizia and
Carson regions
acquisition of territory through the use
of force is a matter of concern for all
of us
protecting the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of all U.N member
states regardless of their size and
their power is our Collective Duty and
our core principle of the U.N Charter
President we do not and will never
recognize the illegal so-called
referenda that Russia has engineered as
a pretext for this further violation of
Ukraine's Independence sovereignty and
territorial Integrity nor they are
falsified and illegal results
we will never recognize this attempted
illegal annexation
a null and void and cannot produce legal
effects
Crimea cursing the parisia donuts and
luhans are Ukraine
we call on all states an international
organizations to unequivocally reject
this attempted illegal annexation
dear colleagues the title of the
resolution we're discussing today is
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
defending the principles of the charter
of the United Nations
that is the only thing we are voting on
and I strongly encourage all member
states to stand up for the charter I
thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of the European Union
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Turkey
Mr President
we thank you for convening yet another
historic emergency special session of
the general assembly a session that was
called because of a war that must cease
immediately
a session that was called because the
security Council failed once again to
fulfill its primary responsibility
Mr President while the whole world is
calling for an end to the world we woke
up once again to shocking news this
morning
the attacks by Russia against several
cities of Ukraine that resulted in
civilian casualties today are deeply
worrying and unacceptable
in the face of these news we reiterate
once again our strong support to
Ukraine's territorial Integrity
Independence and sovereignty
Mr President we also unequivocally
reject the illegitimate referenda
Russia's decision to Annex the Donetsk
lewinsk Harrison and the boricia regions
of Ukraine is illegal
it constitutes a grave violation of
international law
it cannot be accepted
it has been eight years since the
illegal annexation of Crimea
since 2014 the human right situation in
the Crimean Peninsula is severely
deteriorated in particular the human
rights of the crime in tatas have been
systematically targeted
the annexation of Crimea led to nothing
but further damage escalation and
instability in the region
not going to be different this time
the decision to Annex Ukrainian
territory will only serve to further
jeopardize the prospects for peace
we call upon the Russian Federation to
reverse its decision and to return to
diplomacy
Mr President
we all need the international law
and a global order based on rules it is
our duty as member states to defend
legality it is Our obligation to ensure
that conflicts are resolved through
peaceful means we must collectively
ensure that the founding principles of
the UN
enshrined in its Charter are upheld
this is the only way to save ourselves
from this coach of War
with this understanding turkey has
sponsored the draft resolution that will
be put toward this week
Mr President
let me make it clear once again
we do not need nor do we want war in our
region
this war should not have started it
should stop now
it should be brought to an end through
negotiations
together with the United Nations
Secretary General we help the parties to
reach a common understanding on the
grain Corridor initiative we can do more
as a neighbor to both parties
we call on them
once again and reiterate our Readiness
to support and facilitate a peace
process to end this world thank you Mr
President
I think they distinguished
representative of Turkey
and now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of
Singapore
Mr President
it has been more than seven months
since the Russian Federation
a permanent member of the security
Council
launched its invasion of Ukraine
and independent and Sovereign Nation
and a member of the United Nations
Singapore has taken a consistent
position on the need to respect the
sovereignty
territorial integrity
and Independence of all countries
the unjustified invasion of Ukraine
why Russia is a flagrant violation of
international law and the U.N Charter
on the 1st of March this year
the general assembly adopted a
resolution with the support of an
overwhelming majority of countries
to reaffirm its commitment to the
sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine
the resolution we adopted in March also
demanded that Russia must immediately
cease
its use of force against Ukraine and
competitionally withdraw all of its
military forces from the territory of
Ukraine
we are deeply disappointed and extremely
concerned
that after seven months the war in
Ukraine continues unabated
in fact
the war is escalating
with mounting casualties
Russia's recent decision to organize
referenda in four regions
and its decision subsequently to Annex
these four regions
within the Ukraine's internationally
recognized borders is a further
escalation of the conflict
it is also a clear violation of
international law
and the principles
of the UN Charter
the indiscriminate attacks launched by
Russia last night
on civilians across Ukraine
is also clearly unacceptable
we entirely support
and endorse the views of the U.N
Secretary General when he said that the
annexation of a state's territory
by another state resulting from the
threat or use of force
is a violation of the principles of the
U.N Charter
and of international law
the Secretary General added that any
decision to proceed with the annexation
of the donects luhansk kerson and Zappa
regia regions of Ukraine
would have no legal value
and deserves to be condemned
Mr President Singapore would like to
reiterate its position
that the sovereignty
political Independence
and territorial Integrity of all
countries must be respected
the rules-based multilateral system
is built on respect for international
law and respect for the principles of
the U.N Charter
for small states like Singapore
the principles of the U.N Charter and
international law are not matters of
academic debate
they are a matter of life and death
and a system based on the idea that
might is right
is simply unacceptable
Singapore has questioned that has been
placed before the general assembly
and we will support its adoption
by voting yes
and we will do so as a matter of
principle
we believe it is important for the
general assembly
to adopt this resolution by a clear
majority
to send a clear signal to the world
that international law must be respected
sovereignty must to vote in support of
the resolution that has been placed
before us today
in the interest of upholding
international law
upholding the principles of the U.N
Charter
and in the interest of upholding the
rules-based multilateral system
I thank you for your attention
I thank the distinguished representative
of Singapore
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Costa
Rica
Mr President
existence
other states
[Music]
do not change
Ukrainian terrorists
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
communication and the freedom of
registrations foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Mr President
annexations
the aggression against Ukraine I thank
you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Costa Rica
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Poland
Mr President distinguished delegates
colleagues
two days today since early morning we
have been further from a peaceful
solution to the war in Ukraine
massive Russian strikes against civilian
infrastructure and multiply Ukrainian
locations justified by the spiteful
Kremlin regime rhetoric of Revenge
constitutes yet another Grim chapter of
escalation caused by the aggressor
we cannot remain indifferent on to this
unacceptable acts of terrorist nature
Mr President
the charter of the United Nations once
again desperately needs our defense
this is why one by one big and small we
are taking the floor today strongly
declaring declaring our commitment to
the Charter's values
this is why we are retreating our
support for the sovereignty and
territory Integrity of Ukraine
this is why we are condemning the latest
Blanton violation of the very core
principle of international order is
based on
the published position is clear
evidently illegal
they cannot produce any legal effect
and they cannot lead into any binding
action
a single vote in Security Council over a
week ago managed to obscure this reality
fortunately in this chamber there is no
vital right
all members are equal and have identical
Power of One vote
let us make a good use of it even more
so when the Russian Federation tried a
moment ago to deprive us all from the
freedom of speech and expression before
the vote
Mr President
in principle the upcoming upcoming vote
on the draft resolution presented by
Ukraine should be indisputable
a strong and resulting yes
the states which do not recognize the
independence of the so-called donbass
People's Republic
should not recognize their attempted
illegal incorporation to Russia
the former was just a pretext to
accomplish the latter
such behavior is a clear proof of the
policy of the fact that feta complete
pursued by the Russian occupiers and
their proxies both in the past and at
present
not condemning the attempted annexation
means weakening the U.N Charter and
weakening the whole U.N system
one cannot expect U.N institutions to
function efficiently if one votes not
accordingly to the very Foundation they
were established upon
those who undermine the charter cannot
at the same time expect that the U.N
system will deliver in fields of such as
a peacekeeping development Aid or
humanitarian assistance just to name the
few
on the other hand voting in favor of the
proposed resolution
is a much desired sign of solidarity
solidarity not only with Ukraine but of
all those who can share the same faith
in the future
to us Poland this is a very embodiment
of the U.N Golden Rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
Mr President
therefore power and once again goes to
all member states to demonstrate their
determination in defending the basic
principles of international order
let us reaffirm our enduring support for
the territorial Integrity of Ukraine its
sovereignty and Independence
dear delegates
the non-recognition of the Russian
policy of the feta company is a
precondition for diplomacy to work
and peace talks to begin
and just peace is all what we desire
so let's reject the attempted illegal
annexation and give peace a chance
let's demonstrate that we stand by the
UN Charter let's close ranks and vote
Yes yes for the U.N system yes for the
international solidarity thank you
I thank the distinguished Champion that
represented representative of Poland and
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
Indonesia
[Music]
Mr President
respect and adherence to international
law sovereignty and territorial
Integrity are fundamental and a
principled position for Indonesia
it is crystal clear for us that the
settlement of disputes between Country
Must and can only be resolved through
peaceful means in accordance to
international law
only genuine dialogue can bring lasting
solution
War brings us nowhere
the war in Ukraine is evident that only
death destructions and human miseries
are winning
events in the last few hours and days
further confirms this
therefore we reiterate our call to stop
the war
while we welcome the efforts of the
Secretary General and of some countries
to bring the parties to dialogue and to
the negotiating table
the International Community must work
harder to ensure that peace prevails
we have to aggressively wage peace
peace must be our ultimate aim and
priority
Mr President
as the war in Ukraine persists and its
response takes hold the number of
casualties
and refugees continues to search
moreover the war has also caused
far-reaching consequences
billions of people particularly the poor
around the world have become unintended
victims of the war
increasing costs of grain and fertilizer
perpetuated by the War contribute to the
worsening of Global Food energy and
financial crisis
the Secretary General has referred to
this as a one in in a generation Global
cost of living crisis
in which developing countries are
disproportionately affected
it is not too late for us to choose an
alternate path
ending the war is the only way to save
lives and to ease the suffering of
Innocence around the world
the unity of the general assembly is
needed more than ever in addressing the
wider humanitarian impact of this war
Mr President
the referendum of four regions in
Ukraine not only violates the principle
of the U.N Charter and international law
it also further complicates effort to
peacefully resolve the conflict
as the highest resident making body of
the United Nation the general assembly
must resolutely demonstrate its
political leadership
including in the outcomes and resolution
it produces
we must ensure that the general assembly
will not only represent the political
aspiration of the few
we must also avoid a take it or leave it
approach
we therefore deeply regret that inputs
calling to stop the war and for the
immediate and peaceful resolution of
conflicts in Ukraine failed to be
reflected in the final draft of today's
resolution
we remain convinced that lasting peace
can only be achieved on the negotiating
table
we should not let efforts to finding
peaceful solution be held back by
divisions and distrust
Indonesia stands ready to engage
constructively including through
promoting conducive environment for
peace I thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Indonesia
and I I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of Malta
foreign
supports the resumption of this
emergency special session following the
use of the veto by the Russian
Federation on 30th September
most alliances sent with a statement
delivered by the European Union and
would like to add a few remarks in her
National capacity
at the outset malta condemns the most
recent attacks by Russia against Kiev
and other cities across Ukraine such
indiscriminate attacks on civilians are
war crimes and the perpetrators must be
held to account
Mr President as a member of the core
group of the veto initiative we remain
firm in our belief that the general
assembly has a duty to react to the
violations of international law which
are being propagated in Ukraine Malta
strongly condemns and rejects attempts
by Russia to illegally Annex the
donenscluhan saporizia and verzon
regions of Ukraine through the holding
of the Sham referenda these so-called
results constitute a serious and
dangerous escalation they are a blatant
violation of Ukraine sovereignty and
territorial integrity and a show and a
show come and show complete disregard to
the fundamental principles of
international law
the U.N security Council is entrusted
with the maintenance of International
Peace and security
it this is a responsibility it cannot
check the youth or rather the abuse of
the veto by the aggressor in an attempt
to consolidate such acts is
reprehensible
it is something that the rest of the U.N
membership must strongly reject as
incoming members of the security Council
We Stand committed to safeguarding these
principles
equally reprehensible is a rhetoric and
threats concerning the use of nuclear
weapons
together we need to reaffirm our
steadfast commitment to the rules-based
international order we must act in a
decisive and unequivocal manner to
protect the UN Charter this is our
Collective responsibility
we urge all member states to vote in
favor of the resolution we have in front
of us today it is concise and to the
point and addresses recent development
developments in a factual manner the
costs of the war in Ukraine have reached
far beyond Europe and are being felt
worldwide most acutely when it comes to
the unfolding food and energy crisis
Mr President today the general assembly
has the opportunity to send an important
message to the world that the violation
of international law and the sovereignty
of states is not tolerated
these are the principles the founding
members of the United Nations had agreed
to 77 years ago they are the principles
we have all signed up to today it is our
duty to reaffirm them and counter
contempt for them thank you
I think they distinguished
representative of Walter and now I give
the flow to the distinguished
representative of the Netherlands
thank you Mr President and the kingdom
of the Netherlands aligns itself with
the statement just made by the European
Union and I thank you Mr President for
reconvening this emergency special
session for recognizing that these are
not ordinary times
Mr President we are here nearly eight
months after Russia Unleashed its war of
aggression against Ukraine
eight months since this assembly
demanded that the Russian Federation and
I quote immediately completely and
unconditionally withdraw all of its
military forces from the territory of
Ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
eight months that have brought hardship
and food insecurity to people across the
globe plunging millions of the world's
most vulnerable into hunger and poverty
and we are here because like just like
eight years ago with its illegal
annexation of Crimea Russia decided to
ignore the cause of the International
Community and went ahead with the
organization of illegal referenda in
areas temporarily under its occupation
Russia did what the Secretary General
warned not to do and proceeded with the
illegal annexation of Ukrainian
territory and I want to State clearly
the kingdom of the Netherlands will
never recognize the Shem referenda and
the attempted illegal annexation of
Ukrainian territory Crimea
are Ukraine
the kingdom of the Netherlands stands
firmly with Ukraine and will continue to
provide support for as long as it takes
as we will continue to support people
all over the world who are suffering the
effects of this war indirectly from
hunger and poverty to economic
instability also for this suffering we
must hold Russia to account
Mr President it is up to us the member
states of the United Nations to stand
firm for the principles we laid down in
the U.N Charter to make clear that might
is not right
that all of us are bound by the same
fundamental principles and that a veto
does not provide a blank check
our International rule book is no longer
just in Jeopardy it has been trampled by
a permanent member of the security
Council
this is something none of us should
accept
so today's meeting is about defending
the principles of this International
rule book and the charger about
protecting the legal Frameworks aimed at
securing peace justice and human rights
those responsible for violating the
charger and for committing atrocities
must be held to account
the kingdom of the Netherlands with the
Hague as the legal capital of the world
feels a special responsibility in this
regard
and we will not waver in our efforts to
achieve Justice For Those Who suffer
from sexual violence deportation torture
and random killing
Mr President in conclusion this is a war
of Destruction destruction as we have
sadly seen again early this morning with
horrific missile strikes on cities
across Ukraine including the capital
Kiev targeting innocent civilians and
civilian infrastructure which we condemn
in the strongest terms
I should just state it Mr President the
fighting must stop so we renew our call
and Russia to abide by the legally
binding provisional measures ordered by
the international court of justice to
immediately suspend its military
operations and respect internationally
recognized borders
as I said at this same place seven
months ago this war needs to end and it
needs to be ended by those who started
it
I therefore call on all U.N member
states to vote in favor of the
resolution to vote to respect the
territorial Integrity of our fellow UN
member State Ukraine and to vote to
defend the principles of our own Charter
I thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of the Netherlands
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
Luxembourg
Mr President Luxembourg fully aligns
itself with the statement made by the
European Union allow me to supplement
that statement with these remarks made
in our national capacity I wish to
reaffirm the full solidarity of
Luxembourg with the government and
people of Ukraine Luxembourg condemned
in the strongest terms the Russian
aggression against Ukraine we condemn
the deadly missile attacks that were
launched by the Russian Federation
against civilians in Kiev and other
Ukrainian cities the atrocities
committed by Russian armed forces in
Ukraine war crimes and crimes against
humanity we must do everything in our
power to hold perpetrators accountable
and to bring Justice to victims
also condemns the attempted illegal
annexations of the Ukrainian
these regions like Crimea constitute an
integral part of Ukrainian territory
within its internationally recognized
borders as a result of the Russian veto
during the vote held on 30th of
September the security Council was once
again unable to take the decisions
necessary to shoulder its primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
International Peace and security Mr
President I thank you for convening for
resuming rather this emergency special
session of the general assembly this is
a meeting which allows all member states
of the United Nations to speak on a
subject which is of concern to us all
that is the respect of the United
Nations Charter and of international law
faced with the security council's
paralysis paralysis it is now up to the
general assembly to rally for an
international order based on the rule of
law and not on the principle of Might is
right
the illegal annexation orchestrated by
Russia and the Sham referenda that
preceded to constitute a flagrant
violation of the United Nations Charter
and of the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine in these very
difficult times we cannot recall often
enough the text of article 2.4 of the
charter the all members shall refrain in
their international relations from the
threat or use of force against the
territorial Integrity or political
independence of any state or in any
other manner inconsistent with the
purposes of the United Nations
expressed his views unequivocally any
annexation of the territory of one state
by another state as a result of the
threat or use of force constitutes a
violation of the principle of the United
Nations Charter and of international law
and any decision taken by Russia to move
to the annexation of the regions of
Donald
has no legal value and must be condemned
it has no place in the modern world
co-sponsored and will vote in favor of
the draft resolution of the general
assembly entitled territorial Integrity
Ukraine defending the principles of the
UN Charter it is a concise and targeted
tax which is the fruit of a transparent
process
and of international law to support this
what's happening today to you from
Ukraine can happen in other countries
tomorrow the perpetrators of this
aggression are not held accountable for
their acts and if there is no Resolute
and United response from the
International Community in the face of
this flagrant violation of the
territorial integrity of a Sovereign
Nation I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Luxembourg and now I give the floor
to the distinguished representative of
Dominican Republic
thank you very much
to the principles
enshrined in the United Nations
Minister rather for foreign
over the annexed territories
member states of the United States
this situations
many thanks indeed Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of the Dominican Republic
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Albania
thank you Mr President
we meet again in this special emergency
session
since the unprovoked and unjustified
Russian aggression in Ukraine has not
stopped
actually it has worsened
the Sham referendums in luhansk Donetsk
Kirsten and zapore Asia organized in a
rush and at gunpoint and the follow-up
and accession
have demonstrated to everyone including
the most Skeptics
that for Russia there is no
international law
there is no U.N Charter and there is no
Ukrainian Constitution
Albania will not recognize the Sham
referenda and their pretended results no
one should
they have no legitimacy and no legal
effect
luhransk donetskerson and zaporiza are
and will remain Ukrainian territories
and we stand in full support to the
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
Ukraine in its International recognized
borders
colleagues we heard today again the
Russian Federation trying to draw
similarities between the independence of
the Republic of Kosovo and the cham
referenda and its illegal annexation of
four regions in Ukraine
this is wrong
and cynical
comparing an international effort to end
the conflict protect civilians and
establish a peace process to find a
lasting solution which was the case of
kosova with a pure an oven provoked
aggression and the Sham referendum
engineered in Moscow and carried out in
Ukraine is more than artificial
not them to compare the incomparable
noisy shortcuts out of any historical
and political context will help Russia
divert attention from its war of choice
in Ukraine or hide its Bland breach of
international law
in defending the U.N Charter a few days
ago Albanian U.S tabled a draft
resolution in the security Council
again only one country voted against
and blocked the council to act
only one country was on the other side
isolated disconnected from reality
hiding behind the misuse of the veto it
was the aggressor country
this is why we are here today at the
unga The Community of Peace loving
countries who respect the U.N Charter
and uphold the international law
Russia cannot veto the unga
by voting in favor of the resolution we
vote for rules for order for justice for
core principles for peace and security
we cannot allow ourselves to be
indifferent
and abstain cannot be a choice
we should say no to the aggression we
should say no to the next nation of
territory by force we should say no to
this Behavior
this is why we call on the members of
the ga to vote for the resolution as
presented and I thank you
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Austria
foreign
Austria lines itself with a statement
delivered by the European Union
excellencies dear colleagues we meet
here today to discuss yet another
attempt by the Russian Federation to
undermine the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of its neighbor
Ukraine
an attack on one nation but also an
attack on the United Nations Charter on
international law on the foundations
that have guided the relations between
states for over seven decades
the Secretary General has made it
crystal clear this is a matter that
concerns us all
these annexations cannot be reconciled
with the international legal framework
they fill out the purposes and
principles of the U.N Charter
they must not be accepted
I would like to thank the Secretary
General and the president of the general
assembly for their very clear statements
in defense of the U.N Charter and the
sovereignty of Ukraine
no State can stand on the sidelines
while the basic principles of our legal
order are undermined
do we want to live in a world where
might prevails over the rule of law
I don't think so
it is therefore our duty to come
together today and call for an end to
these illegal Acts
this is critical to all of us but even
more so to neutral countries like my own
the so-called referenda that Russia
organized in donets Carson luhansk and
saporizia to prepare this attempted
annexation were equally void of any
legal basis
let me be clear these chamber of Aranda
cannot be called a genuine expression of
the popular will they lack legitimacy
under international law and will not be
recognized by us
there's also another reason why we meet
today the fact that the security Council
was yet again unable to act on this
matter because Russia used its veto
power
for the past few months the council has
been unable to act on what is
undoubtedly the biggest threat to
International Security in decades
it is thereby failing to implement its
mandate
resolution
76-262 the so-called veto initiative was
explicitly passed this year to address
such situations and we welcome the
report that the security Council
submitted to this debate today
I would like to reiterate our call that
the failure of the security Council to
act in such grave situations is a
predicament that needs to be discussed
the new agenda for peace of the
secretary Journal will be an opportunity
to do so but until then its General
Assembly needs to continue to step up
it is clear what needs to be done
the general assembly must send a strong
signal that the world does not accept
this blatant breach of the charter
it must make clear that the so-called
referenda were illegal
that the annexation does not have an
illegal basis
and that it must not be accepted not
even implicitly
this is exactly what the resolution
presented to the assembly proposes it
has been consulted with all regional
groups in a transparent and inclusive
manner
we will therefore vote in favor and
encourage all of you to do the same
I cannot close without referring to the
suffering that this war has caused in
over seven months
thousands of civilians have been killed
millions of people had their lives and
livelihoods uprooted
the Russian attacks against civilian
infrastructure in Kiev and other parts
of Ukraine in the past days are utterly
and unacceptable and must stop
the protection of civilians is not a
choice but a duty under under
international law
we have seen reports of unimaginable
Horrors
in Butcher mariopol and isium previously
peaceful cities that have now become
associated with war crimes torture rape
and mass killings
these crimes must be investigated and
perpetrators held to account
we fully support all efforts to do so
including by the ICC and the commission
of inquiry based in Vienna
the senseless Russian aggression has
blanched the whole world into peril
food shortages storing Energy prices and
nuclear blackmail serve Russia's sole
purpose of trying to subdue its neighbor
with devastating consequences for the
most vulnerable Nations
and let me say one word on the threat of
nuclear weapons
a nuclear threat is a clear violation of
the principles of the U.N Charter
is completely unacceptable
Austria categorically rejects any and
all nuclear threats irrespective of the
circumstances
this underscores the urgency of progress
also on nuclear disarmament
and of moving away from the nuclear
deterrence paradigm
Mr President we call on Russia once
again to stop this war withdraw its
troops from the whole territory of
Ukraine and end the bloodshed
there must be a return to meaningful
negotiations and a sustainable
negotiated solution
this is the only path to peace
Austria stands in full solidarity with
Ukraine the Ukrainian government and the
Ukrainian people
and colleagues we once again call on all
of you to vote Yes on the general
assembly resolution to be adopted at the
end of this debate
to defend the charter to defend
international law I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Austria
and now I offer the floor to the
distinguished representative of
Liechtenstein
Mr President
again we meet in an emergency special
session due to a further escalation of
Russia's aggression
against Ukraine
since its very beginning in 2014 this
aggression has gone hand in hand with an
attempt to deface the fundamental
concepts of international law and the
basic tenets of the UN Charter beyond
all recognition
but the law is clear
be in this Hall must uphold it
not only for the sake of Ukraine
but also to safeguard the international
order to maintain peace and security
Mr President this assembly
unanimously agreed on a definition of
aggression in 1974 at the height of the
Cold War
the very first
of the acts listed in that definition is
I quote The Invasion or attack
by the Armed Forces of a state of the
territory of another state
or any annexation
by the use of force of the territory of
another state or part thereof
and the quote Russia's attempt to
forcibly Annex Ukrainian territory
is thus the latest constitutive Act of
aggression
for which international law provides for
individual criminal responsibility
responsibility that falls on the Russian
leadership
it is incumbent on us in this Hall to
ensure such accountability for the sake
of Justice
but also critically for future
deterrence
this is why we as many others
advocate for special Tribunal for the
crime of aggression
we appeal to all states to join this
effort
in our common interest to maintain
internationally agreed borders and
divert future aggression
Mr President in its attempt to deny the
real the reality of its aggression
Russia violates
the foundational precepts of
international law and of the UN Charter
it violates the prohibition of illegal
use of force in the most Brazen manner
it undermines the principle of
territorial integrity
which is of vital importance for the
maintenance of International Peace and
security
and it makes a mockery of the right of
self-determination
which allows people to freely determine
their political status
Russia's attempt to fabricate election
results through blackmail and
intimidation
and the use of illegal so-called
referenda to justify the redrawing of
Ukraine's internationally recognized
borders by force
evokes diverse memories of colonial
oppression and imperialism
Mr President these violations are not
simply improvisational tactics they are
the latest example of a well-known
Playbook
in 2014
when Russia attempted to Annex Crimea it
also sought to justify its aggression to
Hashem referendum
in Syria as in chechnya before it will
its Relentless targeting of civilians
goes hand in hand the support for
so-called strong man through rigid
elections and elimination of political
opposition
Russia seeks to construct an alternative
reality based on this information
distorting our shared norms and values
while claiming to invoke them
we must collectively resist this attempt
and speak truth
to Brute Force
Mr President this assembly will soon
vote on a text
that condemns
the illegal attempt to Annex parts of
Ukrainian territory a continuation of
Russia's aggression against
Ukraine our consideration
of this text is also an opportunity for
member states to again speak up in
defense of the charter of the United
Nations of territorial Integrity the
sovereignty of States genuine
self-determination and the rule of law
we therefore hope that all of you will
join us in voting in favor of this
resolution I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Lichtenstein and now I give the flow
to the distinguished representative of
Switzerland
Missouri condolences
um
respect foreign
[Music]
territory by Russia violates the
territor's integrity and sovereignty
does not recognize the integration of
Ukrainian territories into the Russian
Federation and we call on Russia to
de-escalate and to withdraw its forces
completely and immediately from
Ukrainian territories
the Direct effects military aggression
the consequences
they manifest themselves
growing polarization among member states
and
let us reject today
initiatives
foreign
I thank you very much
I thank the distinguished representative
of Switzerland and now I give the floor
to the representative of the United
Kingdom
foreign
Mr President excellencies
in February
the general assembly met in an emergency
special session to condemn Russia's
illegal invasion of Ukraine
and today
we meet again
to condemn Russia's sham referenda
and attempted illegal annexation of the
Ukrainian regions of her son
the parisia
luhansk and Donetsk
the largest forcible annexation attempt
since the Second World War
potin is trying to take Ukraine's land
its resources
its identity
in doing so
he is overturning
the most sacred principle in the
International System
that borders
cannot be drawn by force
over seven months into the war
the whole world understands
the terrible cost of Russia's invasion
in Ukraine
families count that cost
in the body's exhumed from Mass Graves
in the rubble of flattened towns
and the lost education for millions of
innocent children
and in the growing list
of friends and relatives
detained
or forcibly deported
through Russia's filtration process
even this morning
Millions across Ukraine
awoke to the sound of air raid sirens
as Russia
carried out one of the largest
bombardments of Civilian and areas and
infrastructure in the war
around the world
people and governments
are suffering
from the unaffordable cost of higher
food and energy prices
as a result of Russia's invasion
everyone's lives have been made more
difficult
and more insecure
and here in New York
we also see the cost in terms of damage
to the UN Charter
the UN Charter enshrines the principle
that no threat or use of force shall be
made against the territorial Integrity
or political independence of any state
we have no way to resolve disputes or
achieve the fundamental goals of the UN
if we concede this principle
if any Rogue head of state can
by force or Fiat
change the borders of another U.N member
this assembly is call on Russia
since the start of its illegal Invasion
has been simple
end this war and withdraw from Ukraine
for the sake of Ukraine
Russia
and the entire un membership
we reiterate this call today
we call on Russia
to end the war
and honor the UN Charter
colleagues
at the end of this debate we will have
an opportunity to vote on a resolution
to condemn Russia's so-called referenda
and illegal annexation
we urge everyone here
to vote in support of international law
the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of all states and the UN
Charter
we urge all members
to vote Yes on the resolution
I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of the United Kingdom and now I give the
floor to their distinguished
representative of Mexico
foreign
Mr President
excellencies excellencies foreign
and annexation
an elected member of the security
Council
and we will
do the same
general assembly
position is grounded in our unwavering
commitment to a support
stringent compliance with Internationals
territory
research
under any circumstances
of
Acts of aggression
integrity
the International Community
United Nations
of sovereign
is
of nations of the world
continues to occur time and time again
many thanks indeed I thank the
distinguished representative to Mexico
ladies and Gentlemen We Have Heard the
Last speaker in the debate on this item
for this meeting
we shall hear the remaining speakers on
Wednesday morning
12th of October at 10 o'clock am in this
home
this meeting is adjourned